SO WE.
WANT TO WELCOME EVERYONE TO THE
APRIL FOURTH
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY
INSURANCE COMMITTEE WE NOW HAVE
A QUORUM LET'S DO A QUICK ROLL
CALL.
DALY HERE.
MAY.
BIGELOW.
AND THEY'RE OUT.
CALDERON.
CHEN.
IF YOU.
COOLEY HERE.
COOPER.
FRAZIER HERE.
GIPSON HAVE THE EUROPE YOU TO
GRAYSON THEIR.
HARPER.
BLITZER.
IT'S GOOD TO CONSENT CALENDAR
HANDLED HERE THERE THREE ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR AB.
BEAUTIFUL YOU SEE THE THREE
ITEMS IN FRONT OF YOU. ANY
QUESTIONS.
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
SENATE CALENDAR.
YES.
DALY AYE MAYES.
I BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE OBRERO.
CALDERON.
CHEN.
CHIU.
COOLEY. AYE.
COOPER AND COOLEY AYE COOPER
I'VE.
COOPER AYE FRAZIER AYE FRAZIER
AYE GIPSON.
GIPSON AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER AYE HARPER
AYE.
GOOD.
MR CHEN. MR CHEN ALSO
YOU GOT HIM.
GOOD.
THANK YOU MR CHEN.
AND.
IS MISS FRIEDMAN HERE.
PRESENT THERE SHE IS.
WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
OUR FIRST PRESENTER WILL BE.
MISS FRIEDMAN ON AB TWO EIGHT
ZERO TWO THE INTERCEPTION OF
INSURANCE PAYMENTS.
THANK YOU CHAIRED ALLEN MEMBERS
I WOULD LIKE TO CHECK THAT THANK
THE CHAIR IN HIS STOP FOR THEIR
HELP ON THIS BILL AS WELL AS ALL
THE STAKE HOLDERS WHO HAVE
PARTICIPATED IN OUR ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
IMPROVE AB TWENTY EIGHT OR TWO
IS A MOVES FORWARD. WE
ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK
DONE ON THE IMPORTANT UNITY
BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO EXPRESS
MY OFFICE IS COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE PURSUING THE CORRECT
LANGUAGE FOR THAT IMMUNITY
BECAUSE.
AB TWENTY EIGHT OH TWO WOULD
REQUIRE ENSURE TO COOPERATE WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CHILD SUPPORT
SERVICES TO MATCH INDIVIDUALS
WHO OH PAST DUE CHILD SUPPORT
WITH THEIR INSURANCE CLAIMS. TO
VERIFY THAT INSURANCE PAYMENTS
ARE FIRST USED TO PAY PAST DUE
CHILD SUPPORT.
CHILD SUPPORT IS CRITICAL INCOME
FOR ELIGIBLE FAMILIES
UNFORTUNATELY MOST FAMILIES ARE
NOT RECEIVING THE FULL AMOUNT OF
MONEY THAT THEY'RE OWED.
RECENT ESTIMATES FROM DEPARTMENT
OF CHILD SUPPORT SERVICES SHOW
THEIR APPROXIMATELY SEVEN
HUNDRED FORTY FIVE THOUSAND.
OPEN CHILD SUPPORT CASES WITH
BALANCES THAT ARE PASSED TO.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE
TOTAL AMOUNT OWED AND PAST DUE
CHILD SUPPORT WAS SEVENTEEN
POINT FIVE BILLION DOLLARS.
AT THE IS SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
BILLION OWED LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA WAS ABLE TO INTERCEPT
ONLY NINETEEN MILLION THROUGH
VARIOUS CHILD SUPPORT INTERCEPT
PROGRAMS.
ONLY FOUR MILLION OF THE
NINETEEN MILLION DOLLARS
INTERCEPT IT WAS CAPTURED BY
INSURANCE COMPANIES WHO
VOLUNTARILY PARTICIPATE IN
CALIFORNIANS INSURANCE INTERCEPT
PROGRAM.
SEVEN UNDERSTATE OTHER STATES
CURRENTLY OPERATES SUCCESSFUL
MANDATORY INTERCEPT PROGRAMS
WHEN TEXAS FIRST IMPLEMENTED
THEIR STATE WHAT INSURANCE
INTERCEPTOR AGREEMENT TWO
THOUSAND NINE THEY SAW INITIAL A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY FOUR PERCENT
INCREASE IN CHILD SUPPORT
PAYMENTS.
IN TEXAS IS LAST FISCAL YEAR THE
STATE INTERCEPTED AROUND SIXTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
AB TWENTY ZERO TO IS NECESSARY
TO ENSURE THAT FAMILIES AND THE
CHILDREN WHO DEPEND ON CHILD
SUPPORT AS A SOURCE OF INCOME
RECEIVE WHAT THEY DESERVE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS KELLY
HEARTY OF CHILDREN NOW A
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION
DEVOTED TO PROVIDING CHILDREN
WITH THE VOICE IN POLICY
DISCUSSIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
BY THE WAY OF THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I'VE RECOMMENDED A
SUPPORT POSITION ON THIS.
MATCH CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. AND.
I AM KELLY HARDY SENIOR MANAGING
DIRECTOR WITH CHILDREN NOW. AND
I'M THANK YOU CHILD SUPPORT IS
CRITICAL INCOME FOR ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES.
I JUST WANT TO REITERATE THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS SOURCE OF
INCOME FOR SUPPORTING THE KIDS
THAT. I'M ARE IN THOSE FAMILIES
THAT RELY ON IT. AND AND.
SEVEN OTHER STATES AS AS STATE
ED I'M.
I HAVE MANDATORY AND SHARP
PARTICIPATION PROGRAMS BUT
CALIFORNIA'S PROGRAM IS STILL
VOLUNTARY. AND LESS THAN TWENTY
PERCENT OF INSURANCE
PARTICIPATE.
I'M.
IN CASES WHERE NON CUSTODIAL
PARENTS ARE NOT COMPLIANT WITH
THEIR SUPPORT INSURANCE
INTERCEPTS CAN PROVIDE A CRUCIAL
LIFELINE TO THOSE FAMILIES. AND
THE KIDS.
I IT'S TIME FOR CALIFORNIA TO
MAKE FINANCIAL SUPPORT A REALITY
FOR THE CHILDREN IN THE STATE
AND I REQUEST YOUR AYE BUT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU FOR YOUR. COMMENTS.
OF ARE THERE ANY OTHER PERSONS
HERE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THIS
BILL.
AND.
JUST FOR.
AND AGAIN THIS BILL WILL.
IF IT PASSES THIS COMMITTEE
WILL PROCEED TO ANOTHER
COMMITTEE.
THE BODY MARK SEVEN PROPERTY
CATLINS HERS ASSOCIATION AMERICA
I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR HER
STAFF IN THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
WORKING ON THIS. OF WE DO
SUPPORT THE CONCEPT AT THE
PHYSICIAN WERE WORKING ON SOME
BASIC CONCEPTS IN THE BILL. OF
FOR EXAMPLE WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IT'S CLEAR THAT IT'S THE
THIRD PARTY NOT THE INSURER
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR MATCHING
THE RECORDS BECAUSE INTEREST NOT
HAVE ACCESS TO THAT TYPE OF
INFORMATION. I WANNA MAKE SURE
THE DE CSS CONTINUES TO BE THE
REGULATORY AGENCY.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO USE
EXISTING SYSTEMS INCLUDING NEWS
THAT'S INVOLUNTARY SYSTEM AND TO
THE DEGREE THAT THAT'S BECAUSE
MANDATORY MAKE IT AS CLOSE TO
THE OTHER STATES IT'S POSSIBLE
TO EASY IMPLEMENTATION THANK
YOU.
CHAIRMAN A MEMBERS JOHN
SHRIEKING REPRESENT ASSOCIATION
A CALIFORNIA LIFE AND HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE DON'T
HAVE A FORMAL POSITION BUT I
WANT IT'S OPPORTUNISTIC ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AND OUR STAFF AND YOUR STAFF
MISTER CHAIRMAN FOR WORKING OUT
THIS ON THIS BILL.
WE DO HAVE QUITE A FEW DETAILS
AND ISSUES TO ADDRESS BUT WE DO
HAVE A SOLID FRAMEWORK TO GET
STARTED AND WE LOOK FORWARD
BETWEEN OUR WORK.
THANK YOU FOR CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR TO TRY TO
RESOLVE THE. ANY OF THE
OUTSTANDING ISSUES THANK YOU.
OTHER.
PERSONS WISHING THE COMMENT.
CHAIR MEMBER FROST BUT THAT THE
PERSONAL INSURANCE FEDERATION OF
LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF THE
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS THAT. YOU LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OF THE
AUTHOR TO WORK ASSN THE DETAILS.
.
THE.
MISS SHARE MEMBERS SHARE REAMERS
ABOUT HALF OF THE AMERICAN
INSURANCE ASSOCIATION OUT ECHO
THE LAST THREE SPEAKERS WE HAVE.
IN CONCEPTS ARE FINE WITH THE
BILL BUT WORKING OUT SOME
DETAILS I'M REFLECTIVE OF MR
SEGMENTS COMMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ROBERT ROUTE THAT TO
COMMISSIONER FOR LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE WERE THE SPONSOR OF
THIS MEASURE WE'D LIKE TO
PROFOUNDLY THANK THE AUTHOR AND
HER STAFF. OF FOR THE
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF WORK HAS
ALREADY GONE INTO THIS MEASURE
WE LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS THIS BILL IS A
LONG TIME COMING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. ANY PERSONS WISHING
TO SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
WELL.
THAT SIR
SIMPLIFIES THINGS A LITTLE BIT.
IS THERE A MOTION ON THIS BILL
YET.
THEN WHEN LIKE TO MAKE A MOTION.
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION AND
SECOND.
MISS FRIEDMAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
MAKE ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR WRAP
UP YOUR PRESENTATION JUST I WANT
TO THANK ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR WORK I KNOW THAT WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO GET THE BILL TO
A PLACE WHERE. THEY'RE GONNA BE
ABLE TO LIVE WITH THIS WHAT'S
GOING TO MAKE A PROFOUND
DIFFERENCE THE LIVES OF CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA.
I NEED TO GIVE THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS A CHANCE TO ASK
QUESTIONS I NEGLECTED TO DO THAT
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS MISTER
FRAZIER.
I'LL TO ME I WAS GOING TO ASK
THE QUESTION IF YOU'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH INDUSTRY
DOES TO ADDRESS SOME OF THEIR
CONCERNS BUT IN YOUR CLOTHES.
YOU
ADDRESS THAT AND SO ON BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL NOT TO MOVE
AT FORT DOT TODAY.
GREAT ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS IF NOT LET'S VOTE.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MACE AYE AYE
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
CABALLERO.
CALDERON.
CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
COOLEY.
COOPER.
FRAZIER.
FRAZIER I GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE
GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE HARPER.
IT HAS.
SIXTEEN ZERO IT SIR THEIR SIX
AFFIRMATIVE VOTES NO A OPPOSE
VOTES AND THERE'S A FEW MEMBERS
WHO WHO WILL BE ADDING ON. AT
SOME POINT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SOON AS LATE
AS SOON AS THEY ARRIVE.
YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU MISS
FRIEDMAN.
BOB TURNING THE GAVEL OVER TO MR
MAYES SO THAT I CAN PRESENT TO
BILLS AND ALL OF.
GO AROUND THE HORN HERE
.
THANK YOU MISTER DALY YOU ARE
WE'RE GONNA START OFF IF IT'S.
YOUR PLEASURE A WITH AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE.
THANK YOU MISTER MAYES.
APPRECIATE THE MOTION.
JUST VERY BRIEFLY.
.
WE'RE ALL FAMILIAR WITH THE MASS
SHOOTING THAT OCCURRED IN LAS
VEGAS SIX MONTHS AGO.
AT THAT. A TRAGIC EVENT THERE
WERE SEVERAL OFF DUTY ORANGE
COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS PRESENT.
THEY SPRUNG INTO ACTION.
AND THEIR WORKERS COMP ISSUES AS
A RESULT IN THIS BILL CLARIFIES
THAT THEY ARE INDEED ENTITLED TO
WORKERS COMP BENEFITS IN ANY
SIMILAR HOPEFULLY NEVER.
AGAIN AN EVENT LIKE THAT BUT IF
THERE ARE OTHER EVENTS FROM.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES.
WHAT A GOVERNMENT?
OFFICIALS AROUND ME
STATE.
A CAN DO.
IN THE FUTURE.
AND I HAVE WELL I HAVE OF COUPLE
WITNESSES WITH ME A TOM TO
MINGUS IS THE. PRESIDENT OF THE
ORANGE COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION.
GOOD MORNING BOB AGAIN TOM TO
MAKE IT A PRESIDENT ASSOCIATION
ORANGE COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN
CALIFORNIA.
PATROLLER PLEASE MAGGI TEAM
THAT ORANGE COUNTY.
AND GOOD MORNING.
FROM HERE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF AB SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE IT
WOULD CLARIFY THAT FULLY A SWORN
PEACE OFFICERS CAN FILE A CLAIM
FOR WORKERS COMPENSATION
BENEFITS IF IF WHILE THE METS.
OF A PURSUIT APPREHENSION.
PROTECTION A PRESERVATION OF
LIFE FOR PROPERTY WITHIN.
STATE OR OUT OF THE STATE.
WITH THE OFFICER SUFFERED AN
INJURY DISABILITY OR DEATH.
AS A SPONSOR OF THIS
LEGISLATION WE'RE PURSUING THIS
COMMONSENSE
CLARIFICATION TO THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR CODE BECAUSE IT'S SIMPLY
THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I DREW IT DURING THE LAS VEGAS
OF LAST LAS VEGAS MASS SHOOTING
SEVERAL. OF ORANGE COUNTY DEPUTY
SHERIFFS WHO ARE OUR MEMBERS.
WERE OFF DUTY.
THEN HER ROPE WE BROUGHT
THEMSELVES AND OTHERS TO SAFETY
THEN IN LINE WITH THEIR TRAINING
AND THE EXPECTATION OF THE
AGENCIES THEY WORK FOR
AUTOMATICALLY RETURNED. A TO THE
KILLING FIELD TO SAVE MORE LIVES
THE SWORN LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICERS TRAINING AND INSTINCTS.
TO SAVE WILL SAVE LIVES
IMMEDIATELY KICKED IN WHEN THE
GUNFIRE ERUPTED THESE MEMBERS
ALONG WITH ALL THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF LAW ENFORCEMENT TO DO THE
SAME THING ARE TRUE HEROES. ONE
OF OUR MEMBERS DEPUTY JOE รณ
ONE OF YOUR BILL AND THE POLICE
SERVICES. WHAT HE DID WAS HE
BROUGHT CONCERT GOERS TO SAFETY?
?
CURE THEM AND THEN RETURNED OUT
TO THE MELEE TO HELP THE WOUNDED
AND WALK WITH DOING THIS HE WAS
SHOT IN THE ABDOMEN. AND THE FI.
NUMBER ARE DEPUTIES ACTED
HEROICALLY EXACTLY WHAT THEY
WERE SWORN TO DO.
HOWEVER WHEN IT CAME TIME FOR
THEM TO GET THE CARE IN THE
COMPENSATION THEY RIGHTLY
DESERVE THE COUNTY OF ORANGE
OBJECTED SAYING THE LAW THEIR
INTERPRETATION OF THE LAW THAT
THEY DID NOT PROVIDE A REMEDY.
FOR THESE OFFICERS BECAUSE THE
INCIDENT TOOK PLACE.
OUTSIDE.
THE STATE LINE.
THAT SHOULD NOT BE THE CASE
WE'RE SEEKING TO FIX THAT IN
STATE OR OUT OF STATE ARE OUR
OFFICERS AND DEPUTY SHERIFFS ARE
NEVER OFF DUTY.
THE PUBLIC.
AND THE POLICE CHIEF IN THE
SHERIFF'S REASONABLY EXPECT LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICERS TO TAKE
ACTION IN THE SITUATIONS IF WE
ARE INJURED OR DISABLED OR DIE
AS A RESULT THE APPROPRIATE
REMEDY. SHOULDBE PROVIDED IT'S
ONLY FAIR WE ASK YOU TO SUPPORT
THE MEN AND WOMEN CALIFORNIA LAW
ENFORCEMENT SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
RICHER MEMBERS RAINY PARRY WITH
THEIR READING ASSOCIATES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION HABITUAL AND PORAC.
OF PROUD TO CO SPONSOR OF THE
BILL.
THESE WERE COMPREHENSIONS WERE
CREATED DECADES AGO FOR TWO
REASONS ONE. WAS TO GET THE
PEACE OFFICER BACK ON THE STREET
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE.
AND SECONDLY WAS THAT WE DIDN'T
WANT PEACE OFFICERS QUESTIONING
WHETHER OR NOT THEY SHOULD
RESPOND ANY ACT COMMITTED THEIR
PRESENCE WHETHER THEY'RE ON DUTY
OR OFF DUTY. THERE'S A
REASONABLY A REASONABLE
EXPECTATION THAT THEY RESPOND
WHEN THEY DO THEY SHOULD BE
COVERED WE DIDN'T WANT THEM
QUESTIONING THAT WE WANTED THEM
SIMPLY. TO RESPOND TO PROTECT
LIFE
SO THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL
CONTINUES TO DO THANK YOU.
OKAY WITH THAT SO THAT YOU THINK
WE HAVE A QUESTION OR MAYBE A
COMMENT FOR MR GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR BRING IT IS
GOOD SENSE WILL MEASURE TO US.
AS A FORMER POLICE OFFICER.
WHEN I SIGNED ON TO DEPARTMENT
AUTOMATICALLY WAS TOLD THAT WE
ARE POLICE OFFICERS TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
MAKE NO DIFFERENCE WHETHER IN
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER STATE. IF
THERE'S AN ISSUE GOING DOWN
WE'RE TO RESPOND TO IT WE COULD
NOT TAKE OFF AND PUT ON.
AT OUR LEISURE WHEN LIFE.
IS BEING A PLACE IN JEOPARDY WE
HAVE TO RESPOND SO I APPRECIATE
YOU AND EXCUSE MY IGNORANCE
BECAUSE OUR IS ALWAYS
AUTOMATICALLY THOUGHT THAT IT
WAS COVERED.
BUT I'M GLAD WE'RE TAKING THIS
SENSIBLE APPROACH TO DO THE
RIGHT THING FOR THE MEN AND
WOMEN UNIFORMS OF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR LEADERSHIP.
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON ABOUT
CENSORED BUT THE GROUP THAT I
ORDERED THE THING MISTER CHAND
OF EUROPE BY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THE FIGURES FOR VICE CHAIR
UMBRAGE ONE TO THINK THAT THE
CHAIR FOR PRESENTING THIS BILL
IT'S REALLY WELL THOUGHT A BILL.
I BECAME RICHARD AT MYSELF TO
REALLY AND WAIT TO HEROES WHICH
MISTER TOM THE MILLIONS ARE
PRESIDENT AND CDS.
AND LIKE MR GIPSON SAID OTHER
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
THEY'RE GONNA PROTECT AND SERVE
AND AND THEIR CREDIT CARD US
WHILE WE SLEEP IT'S ABOUT TIME
THAT WE ALSO GETS UNDER SIXTH.
AS THERE ALWAYS SUPPORTING US
SO I'M VERY VERY HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I WANNA
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR BRING THIS
BILL TO OUR ATTENTION.
ARE THE VERY GOOD MISTER FRASER
THEN ACTUAR IT WE'RE GONNA DO
BECAUSE YOU GOT GUYS GOT
STANDING UP ON WANT THEM TO FALL
OVER I'M SO THAT MISTER FRAZIER
AND THEN WILL. AND HAVE THE
COMMENTS THAT WILL COME BACK TO
THE MEMBERS TO MISTER FRAZIER
MAKING THIS MAYES WILL BE BRIEF.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU.
.
CHAIR DAILY FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND.
.
QUESTION TO THE ORANGE COUNTY.
IS IS HE BEING HELPED THAT THE
OFFICER BEING HELPED OR IS HE
STILL BEING PUT OFF OF BY BY THE
WORKMEN'S COMP SYSTEM HE'S WELL
RIGHT NOW THE CASES ARE JUST ARE
GOING THROUGH THE APPEAL
PROSPEROUS US.
TO THEIR WORK COMP APPEALS
BOARD SO HE HE.
HE'S A PAIN LEGAL COUNSEL IN
THAT REGARD AND IT IS TRAVELING
THROUGH.
THE APPEAL PROCESS AND
ULTIMATELY A JUDGE MAY WILL HAVE
TO MAKE A A RULING BUT IN THE
MEANTIME HE'S HAVE ENDED USES ON
TIME.
WHICH.
THEY WENT THROUGH WE HAVE FOR
CLAIMS.
.
ACTUALLY HE GOT BACK WILL
QUICKER THE.
ONE OF ONE OF OUR GUYS WHO WAS.
TOOK A LOT ACTION MOVING PEOPLE
OUT AND COORDINATING THE
EVACUATION REALLY MESSED UP HIS
LEG GOT SOFT PITCH CITY TISSUE
INJURY HE WAS HE'S BEEN OUT
QUITE A BIT LONGER BUT THEY ALL
HAD TO GO THROUGH THEIR OWN
TIME.
THEY'LL HAVE TO USE OUR PERSONAL
A MEDICAL BENEFITS NOT TO
MENTION. THE TREMENDOUS AMOUNT
OF STRESS AND ANXIETY THAT THAT
IS BECAUSE ON THIS BECAUSE
YOU'RE LOOKING AT LONG TERM
EFFECT ESPECIALLY FOR THE THE.
DEPUTY รณ ONE WHO WAS SHOT HE
HAS RETURNED BACK TO WORK HE IS
ON A LIGHT DUTY STATUS.
BUT THEY REALLY DID HAVE TO
RACE TO GET BACK BECAUSE THEY
WERE BURNING THROUGH THEIR TIME
BECAUSE IT'S UNKNOWN WHETHER
THESE CLAIMS WILL ULTIMATELY BE
ACCEPTED THAT'S WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT WE HAVE THIS
LEGISLATION.
MY BEAT DO. A TRIP FOR THE
INSURANCE COMMITTEE COME DOWN
TALK TO YOUR FOLKS GENERAL'S
COUNTY MEDIA DOUBLE JOE PROBABLY
WILL BE ABLE TO MAKE A TRIP DOWN
HERE IF YOU NEED HIM TO. LEAVE
HIS OFFER THAT NO WE WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT FEEDBACK
ON HOW THIS PRIEST PROGRESSES.
ARE ALSO YOU THINK ABOUT PUBLIC
SAFETY.
WITH THE FIREFIGHTERS WHEN THEY
GO OUT OF STATE AND MUTUAL AID
AND WHAT NOT I MEAN THERE COVER.
I MEAN SO THERE'S A DOUBLE
STANDARD HERE
AND SO WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO AND
I THANK YOU FOR RECTIFYING THIS
AND AND.
.
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU AND IF
WE CAN EVER HELP BUT IT'S NOT
PLEASE HER* LET'S GO TO
INDIVIDUALS SO THEY WANT TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING IVAN ALL TOMORROW
BEHALF OF THE LONG BEACH.
POLICE OFFICERS ASIAN THE
SECOND COUNTY DEPUTY SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA STATEWIDE
LAW ENFORCEMENT ASSOCIATION AND
OF TURN ORDER OF POLICE ALSO IN
SPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
PAC MONEY MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MATTHEW CYBERLINK ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION FOR LOS ANGELES
DEPUTY SHERIFFS IN THE LOS
ANGELES POLICE PROTECTIVE LEAGUE
BOTH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
MORNING MISS CHAIR MEMBERS RANGE
FROM WITH THE RIVERSIDE
SHERIFF'S ASSOCIATION AND ALSO
INCLUDED AMONG THE SURVIVORS IS
RIVERSIDE COUNTY DEPUTY.
JASON MACMILLAN A HERO WHO
KNOWLEDGE SPRING INTO ACTION
WHEN THE SHOOTING BEGAN BUT
IMMEDIATELY ACTED AS A HUMAN
SHIELD TO PROTECT ANOTHER. AFTER
PUTTING IS LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING INTO ACTION TO PROTECT
ANOTHER W. MACMILLAN WAS SHOT
AND IS NOW PARALYZED FROM THE
WAIST DOWN.
HIS WORKERS COMP CLAIM HAS BEEN
DENIED BY RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU
I CAN ASSURE IN.
GOOD MORNING MR VICE CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS ROBERT ROWE THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE.
WE HAVE NO FORMAL POSITION AT
THIS TIME BUT ARE SUPPORTIVE AND
SHOULD BE COMING FORWARD
INFORMED SUPPORT SHORTLY.
TO MISTER GIBSON'S COMMENT
THAT'S PROBABLY SHOULD ALREADY
BE THE LAW RIGHT NOW THANK YOU.
SIR ANYMORE THAT WISH TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT.
I NEXT UP IS ANYBODY THAT WISHES
TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
COME ON UP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE JASON
SHELTER PARA BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF WORKERS
COMPENSATION. WERE PART OF A
COALITION THAT IS OPPOSING LISTA
MENDED.
WE CERTAINLY DON'T QUESTION THE.
INTENT BEHIND THIS BILL UP BY
MISTER DALY OF THE REASON THAT
IT'S BEING DONE I THINK OUR JOB
SOMETIMES IS TO ASK THE HARD
QUESTIONS AS CLAIMS BOOKS WE
OFTEN HAVE TO OPERATE IN VERY
GRAY AREA. UNDERSTANDING THAT A
VERY BLACK AND WHITE SITUATION
IS BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD WE
DO HAVE SOME AREAS THAT WE WANT
TO SIT DOWN WITH STAFF.
IN THE MEMBER AND SPONSORS AND
TALK THROUGH OUR INTENT IN DOING
THIS WILL BE TO REACH AGREEMENT
WITH MISTER DAILY.
AND FOLKS HERE IN THIS BUILDING.
AND AND TRY TO GET OUT OF THE
WAY.
SO THAT BEING SAID A VERY
BRIEFLY WE DO HAVE A COUPLE
CONCERNS THERE IS KIND OF AN
OPEN QUESTION ABOUT WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS DECLARATORY OF
EXISTING LAW.
AND SO WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE THAT.
THAT DISCUSSION AND THERE ARE
ALSO VARIOUS POLICIES THEY'RE
SOMEWHAT CONFLICTING RELATIVE TO
THE QUESTION OF WHETHER OR NOT
PEACE OFFICERS OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. ARE SUPPOSE
YOU'VE INVOKED THEIR POLICE
POWERS ORANGE COUNTY VERY
SPECIFICALLY HAS A POLICY THAT
OUTLINES THAT THE POLICE POWERS
ARE INSIDE OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CAN SEND YOU A
COPY OF THAT. BUT AGAIN THAT'S A
DETAIL THAT WE WANT TO WORK
THROUGH WITH THE COMMITTEE.
AGAIN LIKE WE SAID WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE GRAY AREA THERE
VERY BLACK AND WHITE SITUATION
SUCH AS THIS.
WERE ONE POSITION MAY BE TAKEN
BUT I'LL GIVE YOU AN EXAMPLE OF
SOME OF THE TYPES OF CLAIMS THAT
WE GET. A WE GET CLAIMS FROM
PEACE OFFICERS.
THAT GET INJURED AND THINGS
LIKE TOUGH MUDDER AND THEN MAKE
A CLAIM THAT THEY ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR RESPONSIBLE FOR
STAYING PHYSICALLY FIT. I'M IN
THERE FOR THIS TYPE OF INJURY
SHOULD BE COVERED SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT A LAW CHANGE SUCH AS
THIS WHAT WE'RE REALLY LOOKING
AT IS KIND OF THAT THE GRAY AREA
TYPE OF CLAIM.
WHERE?
AND OF LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICER
COULD BE OUTSIDE OF THE STATE
AND AND CLAIM TO BE ENGAGING IN
POLICE POWERS.
CONCEIVABLY BUT IN REALITY MUCH
LIKE THE TOUGH MUDDER INCIDENT
IT WE WOULD BE IN A VERY TOUGH
SITUATION AS WE WANT TO WORK
THROUGH SOME OF THOSE VERY
COMPLEX ISSUES AGAIN WITH THE
INTENT OF.
GETTING TO SOME SORT OF
AGREEMENT WITH MISTER DALY AND
SPONSORS ON THE BILL I WITH THAT
THANK YOU AND I'M I'M NOT AN
URGENT OF ATTACK.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
VARIOUS STATE PLAYING FOR JUST
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY IF AGREE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY WITH THE CONCERNS
THAT WHERE. I'M EXPRESSED AN
INNER CITIES AND HONESTLY
THANKFULNESS FOR THE HOW I LIKED
BUT WE DO WANT TO WORK OUT THE
DETAILS AND IN A TIME AND IF
VERY APPRECIATE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY PADS MEET WITH STAFF
AND LOOK FOR THE CONTINUING OF
CONVERSATIONS. AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD.
I GOT A QUESTION THREE
OPPOSITION MISTER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE.
YOUR OPENING COMMENTS.
.
IN IN YOUR RESEARCH
TRYING TO YOU MADE MENTION ABOUT
A MURDER SITUATION WHOM BUT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LISA MY MY.
IS SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN
DOCUMENTED. SOMETHING WHERE A
LIFE IS BEING PLACED IN JEOPARDY
BOOM ARM AND.
OFF DUTY OFFICERS FROM ANOTHER
STATE RESPOND.
TO HELP OUT TO SAVE AND PRESERVE
LIFE I THINK THAT'S WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THIS PARTICULAR
SITUATION SO AS YOU ARE
RESEARCHING THIS. AND TRYING TO
COME TO A CONCLUSION.
I THINK THE REASON ONE IS AND
IT IS WHAT I JUST DESCRIBED IS
PLEASE OFFICERS OUT OF
CALIFORNIA RESPONDING. TO A
ACTIVELY INVOLVED SHOOTER.
SOMETHING TO PRESERVE LIFE.
YOU KNOW I CAN'T HELP BUT HEAR
OF THE. SITUATION WHERE THERE'S
AN OFFICER FROM RIVERSIDE WHO
WAS PARALYZED.
AND HIS WORK WAS COP IS BEING
DENIED.
THAT TO ME IS UNCONSCIONABLE
RIGHT AND SO WE DON'T WANT
ANYONE IN UNIFORM TO RESPOND
BASED ON. WE ARE POLICE OFFICERS
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN DOCTORS OUR
DOCTORS TWENTY FOUR SEVEN NURSES
ARE NURSES TWENTY FOUR SEVEN
WHERE THEY BEING CALIFORNIA NEW
YORK WASHINGTON DC AWARE EVER
EVEN IN DIFFERENT COUNTRIES.
LONG AS HE COULD BE
SUBSTANTIATED I DON'T SEE WHY
THAT.
IT'S HARD TO.
SUPPORT SUCH A CLAIM AND WAS
DALY PLEASE ADD ME AS A COAL
AUTHOR OF THIS BILL. AND I WANNA
GO OUT CERTAINLY BE WITH YOU
LOCK STOCK STOCK AND BARREL TO
MAKE SURE THAT HIS BILL GETS THE
NECESSARY VOTES IN NEEDS. DOOR
TO GET THE GOVERNOR'S DESK IS
IMPORTANT THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON AND YOUR OWN AS A CO
AUTHOR SOUND I WAS LOOKING FOR
QUESTIONS AND MORE QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE OPPOSITION.
ANY MORE QUESTIONS I HEARD.
MIGHT SAY NO WE'RE GOING TO GO
TO.
.
THIS QUICKLY.
TO WIN A VOICE THERE BECAUSE A
CALIFORNIA ALSO WITHIN OPPOSE
MUST AMENDED POSITION HELPING TO
WORK IT OUT WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY MORE
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
ALRIGHT THEN WE'LL COME BACK TO
MORE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
MEMBERS OF MISTER COOLEY.
LAW. I JUST WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
IT.
POLICE OFFICIAL IN CALIFORNIA
POLICE OFFICER.
IS SEPARATE THE REQUIREMENT OF.
ARTICLE TWENTY SECTION THREE OF
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION.
THAT THEY TAKE THE STANDARD OATH
OF OFFICE
WHICH WE ALL TAKE.
AS LEGISLATORS.
SO THE WORKERS COMPENSATION
SYSTEM IS DESIGNED TO COVER ALL
WORKERS PROVIDE A REMEDY.
BUT CERTAIN WORKERS ACTUALLY
HAVE UNDERTAKEN THIS AND.
.
A FIDELITY TO AN OBLIGATION.
A NOT EVERY WORKER HAS TAKEN AN
OATH OF FIDELITY TO AN
OBLIGATION.
POLICE OFFICERS I BELIEVE IN
CALIFORNIA DO TAKE THAT OATH.
WHICH INCLUDES THAT PROMISE TO.
WELL AND FAITHFULLY DISCHARGE
THE DUTIES UPON WHICH THEY ARE
ABOUT TO ENTER.
I THINK THIS UNDERTAKING THAT
SOMEBODY TAKES AS A PEACE
OFFICER.
TWO WELL AND FAITHFULLY
DISCHARGE THEIR DUTIES.
IS SOMETHING THAT FRANKLY WE
RELY UPON THEM TO ADHERE TO
THAT.
WITH GREAT FIDELITY.
AND.
.
YOU KNOW.
THE IDEA.
THAT'S A.
PURITY GUARD AT THE IN PARKLAND
DID NOT RUSH INTO THE FRAY.
WHETHER RECESSION WHATEVER THE
PURPOSE ACTUALLY BECAME A SOURCE
OF CONTROVERSY.
I THINK WE ARE DEALING WITH A
CLASS OF EMPLOYEES HAVE TAKEN A
OBLIGATION FOUNDED IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND TO TAKE A WITH THE UTMOST
SERIOUSNESS WHICH IS DISPLAYED
IN LAS VEGAS.
IS I THINK WHAT THAT OATH
REQUIRES.
AND IT BECOMES A LIFE YOU KNOW
EIGHT. IS A CAREER CHOICE IT IS
A HABIT. IT IS COURAGE.
AND A WE SHOULD
RECOGNIZE THE LAW SHOULD ENFORCE
THAT UNDERTAKING.
AS YOU ARE PROPOSING SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY.
AND THEN WE'RE GONNA GO TO
MISTER HARPER AND I THOUGHT I SO
MISTER GRAYSON TRIED HIS BUTTON
WERE YOU UP NEXT TERRACE MISTER
HARPER MISTER GRAYSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I I WANTED
TO THANK THE SPONSORS FOR A
COMING TO ME EARLY ON MAKING THE
CASE FOR THIS IN PERSUADING ME
TO BE IN FAVOR. AYE AND I WANT
TO ESPECIALLY THANK THE.
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
BOTH OF US WERE NOT JUST THAT
RESIDENTS OF ORANGE COUNTY BUT
OF THE COUNTY AND SO. I I THINK
THIS IS A PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
MEASURE FOR THAT FOR THE ORANGE
COUNTY FAMILY AND I'LL BE VERY
HAPPY TO BE SUPPORTING US
THROUGH THE PROCESS.
MR GRAYSON BECK YOU AYE OF.
THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS OF THE BILL BUT IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THE BILL.
DOES PRESCRIBE.
THAT ONE WHILE THE DUTIES BY
WHICH WORKERS COMP WOULD BE
COVERED DOES IT OR. ARE THAT IS
THERE IS THERE PRESCRIPTIVE
LANGUAGE IN THERE THAT WOULD
KEEP.
THE.
EXERCISING AND OTHER THINGS.
OUT OF THE.
.
DOES.
SO I THOUGHT THAT IN THE
TESTIMONY I THOUGHT I HEARD IT.
AND IT'S NOT GRAYSON WANTING TO
CLARIFY MR GRAYSON LET ME
SUGGEST THAT OUR COMMITTEE.
STAFF FOR CHIEF A CONSULTANT
COMMENT ON THAT POINT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THAT.
THE SPECIFIC LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL THAT CLARIFIES.
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS CURRENT LAW?
?
THAT'S THAT CLARIFIES.
WHETHER WITHIN OR WITHOUT OF THE
STATE APPLIES
FOR PRESERVATION OF LIFE AND
PROPERTY.
FOR APPREHENDING OR ATTEMPTING
TO APPREHEND.
A SUSPECT.
PERIOD.
NOT OF THEM THAT THEM.
I UNDERSTAND THE MATTER.
THING.
BUT THAT'S NOT IN THE BILL.
SO THE THE THE LANGUAGES AND
THEIR
CORRECT ME ARE A THANK YOU I
JUST WANT TO CLARIFY THAT. THANK
YOU TO THE AUTHOR AND WOOD.
ALSO BE HONORED TO.
COFFERS WELL.
IT'S ANYMORE I QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
STILL A CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER
GRAYSON FOR YOUR QUESTION AND
FOR CO AUTHORING THE BILL. FROM
THE DISCUSSION IS IS A.
VERY VERY ENLIGHTENING ON THE
SUBJECT OF THE COMPLICATIONS OF
THE WORKERS COMP SYSTEM ONE OF
THE MOST COMPLICATED SYSTEMS
SIR.
IN OUR GOVERNMENTAL.
RETURNED WHEN OUR CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT THAT.
TO ME THIS ISSUE IS BLACK AND
WHITE.
AND WE WANT TO HIGHLIGHT AN
UNDERSCORE THAT OFFICERS
WHO DESERVE WORKERS COMP.
SHOULD RECEIVE IT.
AS WAS MENTIONED BY MISTER
GIBSON AND OTHERS IT'S A TWENTY
FOUR SEVEN.
BUT DUTY THAT THEY. ARE SWORN
TO.
SUE.
SO THAT'S THE THE RATIONALE FOR
THE BILL AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE QUESTIONS AND
COMMENTS AND A. HOPE FOR A
POSITIVE VOTE THANK YOU THANK
YOU YOU DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BUT DALY.
AYE DALY AYE MACE AYE MAYES AYE
BIGELOW. CABALLERO. CABALLERO
AYE CALDERON. CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU.
CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOLEY AYE COOPER BY COOPER AYE
FRAZIER. FRAZIER AYE GIPSON AYE
AYE GIPSON AYE GRAYSON. GRAYSON
AYE HARPER. HARPER AYE.
WELL ZERO.
THANK YOU IT IS OUT DOES THAT
MISTER DALY AYE AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SIX THANK YOU.
THIS SIR.
LAST BILL OF THE HEARING IS SIR
A FOLLOW UP TO.
.
AUDIT THAT I REQUESTED.
FRAUD EFFORTS IN OUR WORKERS
COMP SYSTEM.
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
HAS FRAUD.
.
ANTI FRAUD STRATEGIES.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS HAS ANTI FRAUD
STRATEGIES THE AUDIT LOOKED AT
THE OF THE EFFECTIVENESS THOSE
STRATEGIES IT WAS GENERALLY A
POSITIVE. AUDIT BUT THERE ARE
SOME FOLLOW UPS NECESSARY ANDA.
THIS BILL DEALS FROM WITH THE
FRAUD ASSESSMENT COMMISSION.
IN ITS ABILITY TO USE ON
EXPENDED FUNDS FROM NE YEAR TO
AUGMENT THE FUNDING IN A
SUBSEQUENT YEAR.
IT MANDATES DATA SHARING
BETWEEN DEPARTMENTS AND VARIOUS
OTHER.
STRATEGIES DESIGNED TO PREVENT
FRAUD.
Q. WE DO HAVE A MOTION A SECOND
BUT.
ANY A SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT MARK
SEGMENT PROPERTY CATTLE INSURERS
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL OF WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR ABOUT HIS EFFORTS ON
THIS THE AUDIT.
AND THE OVERSIGHT HEARING.
WE CONTINUE TO BE VERY INVOLVED
IN THE FRAUD WORLD AND WANT TO
CONTINUE.
HIGHLIGHTED SOMETHING THAT WE
WOULD WANT TO CONTINUE AS I SAID
THEY WERE SITE HEARING WANT TO
CONTINUE OUR EFFORTS WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE TO WORK
ON BEST PRACTICES NOBODY TALKED
TO GEORGE MULLER AT THE TO DO
Y..
FRAUD UNIT WE ALSO WANT IMPROVE
THE REPORTING OF WHAT HAPPENED
CITIES CASES BACK TO ENSURE IS
OFTEN WE SEND THESE UP THE CHAIN
WE NEVER GET ANY FEEDBACK ON
WHAT HAPPENS ON THEM. AND WE
ALSO WANT TO TRY AND SEE IF WE
CAN REVIVE THE EXISTING
STAKEHOLDER RELATIONSHIP THAT'S
ALREADY IN THE INSURANCE CO BUT
HAS NOT YET BEEN IMPLEMENTED.
WHICH WOULD ALLOW INSURERS TO
COLLECTIVELY COME TOGETHER TALK
TO THEIR REGULATED HELP.
DETERMINE WHAT TYPE OF FRAUD
TRENDS ARE OUT THERE THANK YOU.
MEMBERS YOUR MEMBERS A MAP
AMERICAN SHARON SOCIAIS XIN I
THINK THE TO.
.
SUBS AND IT DID SUBSTANCE IN THE
BILL ADDRESSES TO ISSUES IN IN
THE FRAUD REPORTED THINK THEY'RE
IMPORTANT ONE IS INCREASED
FUNDING. ON TO FIGHT FRAUD
CERTAINLY THAT WAS A GLARING
NEED IN THE REPORT THE SECOND IS
IS THE DATA SHARING P.
CERTAINLY.
THEIR AGENCIES THAT HAVE THE
DATA AND THEN AGENCIES THAT
SERVICE LAW ENFORCEMENT ARM TO
GO AFTER THE FRAUDSTER SO I
THINK THAT IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
AS WELL. I'M AND WE ARE VERY
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
MISTER MAYES I NEED TO HIGHLIGHT
THAT I AM ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENT.
SUGGESTED
BY THE COMMITTEE STAFF.
I WAS JUST GOING TO ASK YOU THAT
WAS GOING TO ASK YOU THAT.
ANYMORE.
IT ANY MORE INDIVIDUALS IN
SUPPORT OF MR VICE CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS ROBERT ROUTE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE WE HAVE
NO OFFICIAL POSITION AT THIS
TIME BUT. THERE WAS OBVIOUSLY A
LINK THE OVERSIGHT HEARING ABOUT
THE AUDIT.
TWO TOP PEOPLE FROM OUR
DEPARTMENT TESTIFIED AT THAT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH. ALL STAKEHOLDERS.
EVERYONE IS IN AGREEMENT THAT
WE NEED TO FIGHT FRAUD AS
EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE THE ON
IT WAS HELPFUL IN. OUTLINING
SOME IMPROVEMENTS WE'VE ALREADY
BEEN WORKING ON THOSE
IMPROVEMENTS
AND.
LOOK TO CONTINUE WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
IT'S MOVED TO INDIVIDUALS IN
OPPOSITION ANSWER ANY.
SEE ANY ON FILE.
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND
TO MISTY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE I
WILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST TO
SUPPORT VOTE.
ALRIGHT LET'S CALL THE ROLL.
DALY AYE DALY AYE MAYES AYE
MAYES AYE BIGELOW.
CABALLERO. COMING ERA I
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE CHEN.
CHEN AYE CHIU. CHU AYE COOLEY.
COOPER AYE COOPER AYE FRAZIER
AYE FRAZIER AYE GIPSON.
GRAYSON. GRAYSON AYE. HARPER.
NINE ZERO.
THAT BILL OF PASSES ON A NINE TO
ZERO VOTE WILL THE KEEP THE
HEARING OPEN FOR A LITTLE WHILE
SO THAT MEMBERS CAN ADD ON I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS SO.
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION AND HELP
TODAY.
ALL KEEP THE HEARING OPEN FOR
FIVE OR TEN MINUTES.
LET'S OUT ON NOW FOR THOSE WHO
WANT TO ADD ON TRACY.
IF YOU
.
GO.
ARROW.
THERE ARE FIVE.
I CHIU.
I WHO.
COOPER.
NINE ZERO.
AND CONSENT CALENDAR.
CABALLERO.
BOB BAER AYE FOLDERS.
CALDERON I
Q. AND TO AYE.
JAPAN HAS TWELVE.
YOU KNOW KEEP THE HEARING OPEN A
FOR AWHILE LONGER IN CASE SOME
OF THE MEMBERS WHO.
IN. TO VOTE.
.
WANT TO RETURN.
SURE YOU TAKE IT OFF.
MISTER COOPER MISTER COOPER
HERE'S YOUR CHANCE TO ADD ON.
IN THE ROOM A MISTER BIGELOW WAS
ON HIS WAY TO ADD ON AS WELL
MISTER COOPER.
IF IF IF IF IF IT.
YES YES ONE YOU KNOW.
BUT LETTER HOME.
SO CALLING THEM.
BIGELOW.
COOLEY.
FINALLY I.
SEN.
HARPER.
WHERE I?
THAT WE WE GOT ON THE AUDIO
MISTER HARPER YEAH.
YOU BETCHA.
RIGHT.
ARE THEY ARE THERE ANY WE'RE
WAITING FOR MR BIGELOW TO RETURN
HE SAID APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
RIGHT NOW.
TWENTY A NO. PROPERLY BY
COOLEY AYE.
NO I.
RESERVE UNTIL NEXT TIME THAT.
YEAH. THE NEXT YEAR.
WHILE.
ONE OF THE.
ALTHOUGH WE ENTERED.
PREVIOUS
.
CAN ONLY ADDED.
THE FLORIDA.
PUBLIC. REQUIRES A LOT OF.
COMING BACK
.
I PART OF IT.
BUT HOW.
OF
.
WELL.
PAGE.
ABOUT EVERY OTHER.
ARTICLE.
BECAUSE.
YEAH.
THERE ARE
THIS IS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR MR
BIGELOW TO ADD ON.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY NINE BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE.
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX BIGELOW.
A LEAD TORNADO TO BIGELOW.
BIGELOW AYE.
THANKS FRANK.
IT WAS WORTH YOU BETCHA. YOU
BETCHA
WELCOME BACK.
AB TWENTY FORTY SIX.
SEC GIPSON AYE.
AND.
YOUR RECORD ON EVERYTHING NOW
MY.
THANK YOU.
THIS HEARING IS ADJOURNED